bonsoir et bienvenue dans
l'hebdopolitique votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 épisode 245 mon
invité et ce soir le député renaissance
de la 12e circonscription des Yvelines
car le livre
[Musique]
de politique
car le livre bonsoir bonsoir comment
allons-nous vous êtes député Renaissance
donc de la 12e circonscription des
Yvelines 6 ans au pouvoir le 7 mai 2017
Emmanuel Macron était élu président de
la République depuis le premier instant
de ces six années je tâche à la
responsabilité qui est la mienne et dans
la fonction que vous m'avez confiée
devrait au service de tous les Français
de nos enfants et de l'intérêt général à
écrit le président dans un courrier
adressé aux Français qui ont voté pour
lui alors le premier quinquennat a été
rythmé par des de nombreuses crises à
faire Benalla mouvement des gilets
jaunes première manifestation contre la
première tentative de la réforme des
retraites crise du covid ensuite puis
cette guerre en Ukraine et cette
contestation sociale qui se poursuit
encore sur la réforme des retraites quel
bilan faites-vous vous de ces six années
au pouvoir et du chemin parcouru donc
par la majorité présidentielle
je suis maire de Poissy entre 2014 et
2022 et la relation que j'ai pu avoir
avec le président de la République elle
date quasiment du début de l'engagement
qui a été le mien au détour notamment
d'une visite du président dans un
endroit que vous connaissez bien sur
Radio sensation qui est le quartier de
la Coudray où je suis né sur un exemple
de rénovation urbaine et le courant est
vite passé parce que d'abord le
président un langage simple un langage
direct et comprend le sujet des maires
des maires de terrain le paradoxe et
vous avez raison c'est que notamment au
niveau de la crise des gilets jaunes
autant le président avait été élu sur un
programme de réforme qu'il voulait
mettre en oeuvre très rapidement autant
la manière de les mettre en place était
une espèce de dimension verticale je
décide vous exécuter et j'ai dit au
présent un jour président ça se passe
pascope ça se passe pas comme ça venez
voir celles et ceux qui sont aux prises
avec la réalité le problème de méthode
au début notamment des relations peu
compliquées avec les maires notamment et
la MF oui enfin je parle pas de la MF
qui
depuis devenu un peu plus un syndicat de
bon sens et qui restait un syndicat
politique avant l'arrivée de David
Lisnard mais j'avais dit au président
faut s'appuyer sur celles et ceux qui
sont en prise directe avec la réalité du
terrain c'est-à-dire les maires et donc
partir du terrain et c'est ça qui m'a
plu c'est ça qui m'a plu chez lui et
puis aussi disons-le le fameux en même
temps c'est tout simplement la la le
récit du général de Gaulle en 58 dans la
constitution de cette 5e République il y
a la France c'est pas la gauche la
France c'est pas la droite il y a de
courant le courant de la réforme et le
courant du devoir et de la tradition
c'est ce qui m'a séduit chez le chez le
président ce que j'en retiens c'est que
on a tous un combat pour l'emploi
lorsqu'on émerve lorsqu'on est conseillé
départemental peut-être qu'on y
reviendra quand on est coincé régional
quand on est qui plus est présent la
République c'est vraiment le combat pour
l'emploi et pour combattre l'emploi faut
travailler pour réduire le chômage et
c'est vrai que cette courbe inversée du
chômage depuis 6 ans elle est manifeste
on est à 7,2% de taux de chômage ça
n'est jamais arrivé depuis 15 ans on a
multiplié quelque chose qui me parle
beaucoup je crois vous parle beaucoup et
parle beaucoup à noter les spectateurs
et aux auditeurs c'est l'apprentissage
300 000 il y a 7 ans près de 900 000
aujourd'hui c'est une voie pour l'emploi
cette certainement pas un passeport par
défaut vous avez vu j'imagine comme
beaucoup de monde ces images du 8 mai
avec le président remontant les
Champs-Élysées vidés les manifestations
avaient été interdites dans dans le
cycle auteur il y avait pas de
rassemblement populaire pour ce 8 mai
sur les Champs-Élysées ou encore même un
peu avant lors de cette finale de la
Coupe de France le président a été
contraint de saluer les finalistes dans
le couloir c'était quasiment du jamais
vu j'ai pas le souvenir d'avoir vu un
président ne pas pouvoir aller sur le
terrain est-ce que ce n'est pas mauvais
en terme d'image en termes de
communication c'est ces images envoyées
aux Français alors de deux choses l'une
d'abord pardon de sujets le premier que
vous évoquez concernant le le 8 mai on
voit bien que depuis quelques trois ou
quatre mois avec la réforme des
retraites ce pays cette société est
devenue de plus en plus clivante je
dirais que le covid est passé par là
également mais on voit bien que le
ruissellement comme je le dis de la
dernière législative à l'Assemblée gagne
aussi du terrain ici dans notre
assemblée disons-le c'est très compliqué
de pouvoir examiner les lois la fabrique
de la loi parce qu'on a notamment une
opposition d'extrême gauche qui nous
empêche qui provoque qui insultent qui
injurie parfois et je le dis ça
ruisselle aussi sur sur le terrain
maintenant évidemment tout n'est pas
parfait évidemment que cette réforme des
retraites elle a été mal embauchée dès
le départ il aurait fallu passer plus de
temps je reviens sur ce que j'ai sur la
mer auprès des Français pour prendre un
peu plus de comme je dis de bourpif dans
le dans le rubis d'être à portée de bave
comme le dit le président Larcher ce qui
permet là la confrontation mais pour
avoir accompagné présent dans la
République par exemple dans le Bas-Rhin
tout ce qui concerne les les
casseronnades comme on dit ou les
casseroles tout ça est orchestré ça va
morchestré par l'extrême gauche les
syndicats d'extrême gauche je parle pas
de la CFDT c'est pas je parle de la de
la CGT et c'est pas ça la France il y a
une France aussi silencieuse qui n'est
pas forcément d'accord avec le président
qui parfois l'est et qui fait qu'on peut
échanger avec lui donc je peux
comprendre alors c'est un excès mais je
suis frustré moi comme vous de voir les
Champs-Élysées vides au moment du
passage du Président je fais
différenciation
Corentin lonszo sur le Stade de France
parce que j'y étais qui a remis au goût
du jour le fait que le président aille
saluer les joueurs c'est le président
Macron dès son élection en 2017 ça
c'était pas fait depuis des événements
et que avec le président Hollande et
également le président Sarkozy la star
de cette finale c'était pas le président
Macron c'était effectivement les joueurs
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il a
préféré être discret sur le sujet et
d'ailleurs les Français ne se sont pas
trompés de combat les supporters ne se
sont pas trop bêtes combats quand il y a
eu des distributions de de carton rouge
ça n'a pas pris j'ai fait une
intervention sur un plateau d'un de vos
confrères le samedi après-midi puisque
j'étais au stade on m'a dit vous allez
voir une Branca historique au Stade de
France bah historique historique rien du
tout il s'est strictement rien passé
c'est pas 200 allez 300 sifflets au
stade au Stade de France sur 68000
personnes présentes qui ont je dirais
pipé les dés les Français sont
responsables et à ce point un match de
foot exactement c'est ce que j'allais
dire allez orchestrer politiser le plus
grand événement sportif de France qui
mêle amateur et professionnel parce que
je rappelle que la finale de la Coupe de
France c'est les professionnels mais
également les amateurs de football je
crois que c'était très mal venus et ça
très mal été pris par par les Français
qui n'étaient là que pour une chose fait
en sorte que ce soit la plus belle fête
de l'année et bravo à Toulouse pour sa
belle victoire au cours de ces six ans
il y a eu donc certains projets il y a
eu la réforme des retraites donc il va
passer dans le premier quinquennat mais
qui maintenant donc a été donc a été
adopté
sur la réforme des institutions
maintenant c'est l'autre grand dossier
attendu notamment et annoncé par
Emmanuel Macron lors de son premier
quinqu pas la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a le Brown Pivet va
lancer un groupe de travail
transpartisans dans deux semaines pour
réfléchir donc à plusieurs thématiques
autour de la réforme des institutions
c'est un dossier très attendu notamment
par les élus locaux et vous en savez
quelque chose en tant qu' ancien
conseiller départemental des Yvelines et
mères de Poissy alors commençons par
l'Assemblée nationale d'abord sur cette
réforme des institutions aujourd'hui il
y a 577 députés élus donc au scrutin
uninominal majoritaire à deux tours 12
d'ailleurs donc dans les Yvelines est-ce
que vous êtes fous favorable à
l'installation de la proportionnelle
donc au niveau de départements donc
c'est une volonté notamment portée par
vos alliés du MoDem alors déjà faut
avoir une vision il faut avoir une
vision pour notre pays et poser un
diagnostic quel est le diagnostic il y a
de moins en moins de Français qui vont
voter il y a plus de la représentativité
aussi dont on parle il y a de moins en
moins de Français qui croient en leurs
élus quels qu'ils soient à l'exception
des maires qui sont parce que les mers
sont les fantassins de la République et
encore une fois connaissent parfaitement
le terrain parce qu'il passe beaucoup de
temps sur sur le terrain c'est ça
l'enjeu donc l'enjeu là vous me parlez
d'une dose de proportionnelle je crois
le dire à travers vos propos mais elle
existe la proportionnelle quel est le
résultat de cette majorité relative
c'est bien le résultat d'une
proportionnelle qui ne dit pas son nom
lors des dernières élections
législatives on a un calque de notre
pays voulu par par les Français je suis
pas sûr que ce soit une urgence de la
situation d'autant que je pense ce qui
nous manque aujourd'hui dans notre pays
c'est une plus de proximité entre l'élu
et l'administrer or la proportionnelle
pourrait faire que sur un scrutin de
liste nous ayons par exemple dans les
Yvelines quelqu'un qui finalement soit
originaire de Bretagne ou du Loiret
premièrement deuxièmement oui il faut
revenir au retour encadré et
parfaitement encadré du député-maire 250
mères en 2012 0 aujourd'hui et les mers
sont les plus plébiscitées est-ce que ça
réduit la fracture démocratique
absolument pas et est-ce que c'est pas
une hypocrisie bien sûr que c'est une
hypocrisie première langue on peut être
mère et qu'on sait départementale on
peut être mère et conseiller régional on
peut être député conseil départemental
ce que je suis
en cumulant les indemnités on peut être
mais député et conseiller régional et on
ne pourrait pas être mère et député sans
être à l'exécutif non c'est une vaste
hypocrisie bien sûr quel temps il faut
trouver le temps je passe beaucoup de
temps sur le terrain parce que j'ai
conscience que les idées que nous
modestement devons faire monter au
niveau de l'Assemblée doivent venir du
terrain donc le concours Lépine de celui
qui va être le plus présent à
l'assemblée très peu pour moi je pense
que en revanche je fais partie
modestement d'un de ceux des collègues
des 577 collègues députés à passer
beaucoup de temps sur le terrain parce
que c'est pour moi le sérum de vérité
alors aujourd'hui la question qui qui se
pose sur cette réforme des institutions
pour le nom cumul des mandats que vous
évoquez c'est où est-ce qu'on fixe le
seuil est-ce qu'on peut être député et
maire d'une petite ville député maire
d'une ville reviennent député maire
d'une grande ville quelle est votre avis
là-dessus d'abord disons que le
Président de la République et le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher sont
en phase sur le fait de pouvoir
réintroduire ce cumul encadré de députés
mère ou de sénateurs merde ça c'est
quand même important c'est la première
chose la formation que je vous donne
c'est que cette réforme des institutions
n'interviendra pas avant les prochaines
élections sénatoriales c'est que UFD
donc c'est pour la fin d'année et merci
qui auront lieu en septembre les
élections et bravo à Gaëlle brun Pivet
notre président de l'Assemblée nationale
de mettre en route ce sujet ce sujet
dont on évoque au quotidien les contours
avec les collègues maires typiquement
dans la 12e circonscription 23 communes
tous les mois je réunis les maires il y
a pas une seule réunion je le dis alors
vous vous le voyez pas mais devant mon
attaché parlementaire Julien Di Maggio
où on nous parle pas du retour du cumul
des députés mères soy ou pas seul
franchement
moi je suis pas omniscient sur le sur le
sujet et les les cercles de réflexion
ont mis en place notamment par Yelle
brun privé et puisque nous nous allons
remonter comme contribution notamment
avec mes amis générations terrain dans
comme vous le savez je suis président
feront en feu en Europe et puis c'est
comme ça que nous devons cheminer il me
semble à l'instar de ce qu'on aimerait
faire à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
table également la réforme du conseiller
territorial c'est un sujet qui revient
souvent donc les conseillers
départementaux si c'est très forme est
appliquée siège réellement dans le
conseil régional certains ont peur que
les régions deviennent des des organes
de représentation des intérêts
départementaux qui peuvent être parfois
divergents est-ce que vous pensez que ça
pourrait être le cas aussi mais un peu
la même chose que vous venez de faire
c'est que vous m'avez posé une question
je je
ne l'ai même pas comprise parce que mais
vous êtes complètement raison mais c'est
tellement compliqué dans ce pays
commençons par rendre les choses un
petit peu simples est-ce que la
compétence du conseil départemental qui
consiste à gérer les collèges la
compétence des de la région qui consiste
à gérer les lycées ne pourraient pas
être mutualisé est-ce que pendant le
covid il était à je dirais cohérent que
le matin j'aille distribuer des masques
puisque j'étais conseiller départemental
dans les collèges et que l'après-midi ma
collègue et amie Alexandra Dublanche
conseillère régional d'Île-de-France
face la même chose dans les lycées de la
ville de Poissy vous voyez qui est
quelque chose qui doit être un petit peu
simplifié cette idée elle vient de rando
à Nicolas Sarkozy qui lui appartient
elle vient de Nicolas Sarkozy c'était
pour en fait un simplifier de mutuelle
mutualiser les ressources et les moyens
à mon avis dans la hiérarchisation des
priorités nous n'en sommes pas là en
revanche limiter un certain nombre
d'élus pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais de
grâce simplifions simplifions
l'administration de de ce pays c'est ça
qui pourrait le quotidien des Français
c'est pas autre chose et si on
commençait par simplifier
l'administration certainement
d'administration dans le dans le pays et
on pourrait en parler lors des la
réforme des institutions je peux vous
dire qu'on la vie des Français et ça
leur donnerait peut-être un petit peu
plus envie d'aller voter enfin le retour
du septennat est également évoqué avec
des élections législatives mi-mandat un
peu à l'américaine qui permettrait donc
de pouvoir revoter et redonner donc son
avis en cours de mandat est-ce que vous
seriez favorable au retour du septa
alors ça peut être ça peut être une
espèce de soupape je vais pas dire de
sécurité mais mais de voilà d'oxygène ça
c'est c'est envisageable il faudrait pas
qu'on ait des législatives anticipées
qui poursuivent ce mythday enfin ce
bitship donc vous évoquez l'original aux
États-Unis tous les tous les trois ans
ou tous les trois ans tous les trois ans
et demi l'avantage de la situation
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on pensait que
après l'élection d'un président ou d'une
présidente
l'assemblée uniforme elle a été c'est
que non elle est française sont pas dupe
on peut voter pour un président une
présidente à la présidente et pas lui
donner un ressemblant et moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt cohérent à une
condition c'est qu'on puisse travailler
pour le pays et pas simplement pour pour
les parties parce que aujourd'hui c'est
quand même très compliqué de pouvoir
faire avancer les les lois dans ce pays
parce qu'on a de l'obstruction de la
provocation des insultes je le disais
tout à l'heure je pense qu'il faut qu'on
doit tous être exemplaire et je nous
mets également nous dans voilà ça nous
arrive aussi de dire des bêtises et il
faut voilà il faut les reconnaître il
faut s'excuser et repartir de bon pieds
toujours avec Carl l'olive député de la
douzième circonscription des Yvelines
députés redescence le 9 mai dernier
c'était la journée de l'Europe pour
marquer le coup les députés de la
majorité ont proposé une loi pour faire
voter l'obligation donc pour les Mairies
d'arborer le drapeau européen sur leur
façade d'une pratique déjà très répandue
dans les plupart des mairies de France
Pourquoi la rendre obligatoire ça serait
nécessaire selon vous je pense qu'il
faut que entre guillemets les règles
soient les mêmes dans les 35000 communes
de notre de notre beau pays et vous le
disiez Corentin je vais ce titre
certains n'ont pas attendu
et un certain nombre de maires n'ont pas
attendu de de placer le drapeau européen
adossé
bien sûr et depuis de longues dates il a
toujours été présent dans mon bureau à
partir de 2014 comme il l'est dans le
bureau de Sandrine Berneau Dos Santos
qui a pris le relais à la ville de
Poissy avec maestria non je pense qu'il
faut qu'on soit conscient que nous
faisons aujourd'hui partie d'un
continent qui est un continent fort à
une condition c'est qu'on travaille
ensemble pas chacun dans son couloir je
suis souvent que seul on va plus vite et
qu'ensemble on va plus loin on va plus
loin parce que l'Europe est là donc il
faut une France forte dans une Europe
engagée et c'est pas incompatible et
encore une fois c'est pas l'un à côté de
l'autre donc moi je me satisfais de
cette de cette loi si je devais prendre
un tout petit peu de recul je me dis
quand même il faut en arriver là pour
imposer un certain nombre de choses bah
oui parce que y compris certaines
certains édiles sans les sans les nommer
font parfois aussi l'obstruction à
l'endroit de de l'Europe simplement par
dogmatisme et on a appris aussi
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été invité du 2 au
4 juillet pour une visite d'État en
Allemagne il s'agira de la première
visite d'état d'un président français
donc en Allemagne depuis 2000 à
souligner l'Élysée une visite qui se
déroulera donc l'année des 60 ans du
traité de l'Elysée on a célébré le 8 mai
justement la victoire sur l'Allemagne
nazie c'est important aussi de célébrer
cette paix franco-allemande et cette
cette franco-allemande 60 ans après avec
ce traité de l'Elysée à qui dites-vous à
Poissy nous sommes jumelés avec une
ville allemande qui est la ville de
pierre massens qui est une ville qui est
près de la frontière près la frontière
française c'est extraordinaire ce qui a
voulu notamment général de Gaulle de
pacifier le relation entre la France et
l'Allemagne il fallait avoir envie avec
avec le chanteur
adanware de pouvoir de pouvoir le mettre
le mettre en place c'est ça l'origine
des des jumelages et c'est ça aussi la
fraternité entre la France et
l'Allemagne l'Europe c'est deux moteurs
c'est la France la France et l'Allemagne
et je dirais que cette combinaison
hybride agrémentée évidemment de de
force soutien je pense à nos amis
espagnols à nos amis portugais nos amis
italiens de pouvoir construire et de
pouvoir continuer à faire en sorte que
la résilience ça soit une résilience au
quotidien et j'insiste là dessus sur
cette question Corentin vous me posez
entre la France et l'Allemagne parce que
le devoir de transmission et pour moi
très important on peut pas comprendre ce
pays on peut pas commencer dans ce pays
si on oublie les origines les épisodes
qui malheureusement ont causé des
cicatrices qui sont des des cicatrices à
vie et le dernier exemple voilà
l'hommage à Jean Moulin le père du CNR
est pour moi une très belle initiative
et dans le même temps à Poissy il y a
une quinzaine de jours maintenant et
bien il y a eu cette commémoration comme
comme j'ai pu la vivre à Orgeval à
Crespières et c'est formidable parce que
c'est intergénérationnel et il faut
absolument continuer ce devoir de
transmission j'aimerais car le livre
maintenant qu'on évoque un autre dossier
d'actualité la situation à Mayotte ou
l'opération wambushu se poursuit pour
lutter contre l'immigration illégale et
la délinquance dans le sang une énième
département français le président des
Comores Azali Assoumani a une nouvelle
fois réaffirmé la souveraineté des
Comores sur Mayotte et que c'est la
France qui est responsable voire
coupable de ce qui s'y passe alors que
représente Mayotte pour vous élu des
Yvelines on a vu les mahorets clamer
encore et encore leur amour pour la
France et leur envie d'être d'être
français récemment alors moi je peux
vous parler du président des Comores
plutôt vous parler effectivement des
Mahorais qui sont des Français à part
entière c'est notre sang une ième
département depuis 1800 1841 je crois le
plus bel hommage que j'ai entendu ces
dernières semaines c'est c'est celui de
de ma collègue liotte Estelle Youssoupha
Youssoupha qui explique que les marais
se sont battus pour être français et que
le cœur de la France vibre au quotidien
à Mayotte et qu'il faut absolument en
avoir conscience et c'est vrai que la
distance fait parfois loin des yeux loin
du cœur certains l'oublient et bien les
élus ne l'oublient pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a répondu
aux élus et au Mahorais pour faire
régner tout simplement la démocratie et
faire en sorte qu'il y ait pas un
centimètre carré dans notre pays Mayotte
inclus qui
à celles et ceux qui veulent vivre en
France et moi je suis ravi qui est qui
est eu cette opération par des lois du
terme mais c'est pas le terme approprié
mais il faut absolument que que la loi
règne et qu'elle soit la même pour tout
le monde il y a pas de il y a rien qui
doit être au-dessus au dessus de la loi
après celles et ceux qui veulent devenir
français il y a des moyens de pouvoir le
faire mais je dirais que l'immigration
d'endroits et on pourra peut-être en
reparler doit être vu je dirais comme
une digue une digue pour pour qu'il y
ait pas de d'obstacles et surtout qu'il
n'y ait pas une expansion de celles et
ceux qui finalement n'ont rien à faire
sur un territoire non pas qu'il ne soit
pas les bienvenus mais ce n'est pas leur
territoire tel que vous vous avez pu le
signifier que le président des Comores
enfin car le livre parlons sport pour
finir et parlons du du PSG qui va très
bientôt prendre ces quartiers à Poissy
avec donc le nouveau centre
d'entraînement en tant qu' ancien maire
vous avez suivi depuis de selon moi de
longues années ce chantier 17 terrains
de de sport et la création d'un nouveau
stade aussi pour les équipes de de
jeunes c'est un dossier important pour
Poissy qui va aboutir dans les mois qui
arrivent je dirais c'est un dossier
important pour le territoire pour les
Yvelines parce que le Paris
Saint-Germain a failli quitter les
Yvelines il cherchait une surface digne
des ambitions du Paris Saint-Germain et
s'il savait pas été le cas il aurait
quitté vraisemblablement le département
de de sources sourds sur ce sur Oui
c'est un totem c'est c'est formidable
pour pour le territoire c'est c'est 500
emplois pendant la durée des travaux
c'est 350 millions d'euros d'investis
par par la gouvernance du du
Paris-Saint-Germain c'est 17 terrains
c'est le football c'est Lorde c'est le
seul judo c'est une clinique ce sera ce
sera deux hôtels et l'information que je
vous donne presque en primeur c'est que
dans un mois dans un mois l'ouverture de
la section professionnelle pour les
professionnels et donc à partir de la
saison prochaine les professionnels
s'entraîneront ici à Poissy comme
féminine comme la préformation comme la
formation il y aura par exemple 15
classes qui seront dévolus à la
formation des jeunes futurs
professionnels du Paris-Saint-Germain
ici à Poissy et on est sur un cercle
vertueux de l'économie locale c'est
important parce que c'est pas le Paris
Saint-Germain qui vient s'installer sur
75 hectares c'est pas ça Germain qui
vient s'installer à Poissy avec Poissy
avec les communes les vitraux avec le
département avec sa fondation avec son
association et une partie de la
direction administrative du
Paris-Saint-Germain qui vient
s'installer c'est vraiment c'est
formidable c'est formidable pour
l'emploi je le disais c'est notre
premier combat dans la foulée Porsche et
lui s'installer Alfa Romeo vient
également s'installer stellantis
indirectement via installer un campus
XXL pour Poissy on est revenu le premier
bassin d'emploi je continue à dire nous
vous voyez comme si j'étais encore mère
et on est redevenu le premier bassin
d'emploi de la vallée de Seine alors ça
c'est pour le centre d'entraînement mais
il y a aussi la question du stade où les
négociations avec la Mairie de Paris
sont très
[Musique]
entre guillemets est en vente c'est 600
millions d'euros il y a au moins 600
millions de rénovations si on veut en
faire un joyau digne de snow donc le
Paris Saint-Germain a eu raison et le
Paris Saint-Germain a raison encore une
fois de regarder un autre un autre
endroit je disais sous forme de bouddhad
que si la ville de Poissy pouvait
observice avant de service c'est ce que
je disais à l'époque pour le centre du
le centre du PSG la vérité c'est qu'il y
a d'autres secteurs qui sont privilégiés
et peut-être également vous avez raison
dans les Yvelines vous vous êtes rendu à
Évry également il y a pas très longtemps
pour aller rendre à saluer donc ceux qui
sont à l'origine du défi de la lucarne
d'Evry qui sera donc de retour dans les
Yvelines vous l'avez annoncé sur une
vidéo Twitter il y aura 10 dates
organisées par le département des
Yvelines pour que chacun puisse relever
ce défi alors est-ce qu'on a déjà une
idée de quelle ville pourrait accueillir
l'événement dans les mois qui qui
arrivent d'abord Corentin si vous me le
permettez je voudrais quand même
rappeler la genèse de cette de cette
initiative nadiaque est
une collègue députés de Conflans à
l'époque mise de la ville m'avait confié
un rapport sur l'insertion des jeunes au
travers du sport entre 12 et 17 ans
parce qu'on appelle les qpv les
quartiers en politique de la ville j'ai
fait 200 auditions et parmi les
auditions je suis allé interviewer ces
jeunes d'Evry pour leur lucarne le fait
de de taper dans le dans le balance ou
je sais que un ami qui travaille chez
vous qui s'appelle Franck et Dark qui
connaît très bien le football
taper dans le ballon comme un coup franc
et mettre le ballon dans une petite
lucarne dans un quartier dans un
d'ailleurs relevé le dans un immeuble
moi j'y suis allé d'abord pour écouter
ces jeunes voir quel était leur idée
derrière le fait est qu'ils ont fait un
tour de France et le fait est que
c'était une manière aussi de valoriser
nos quartiers qui sont tellement
stigmatisés et donc déjà l'an passé
après avoir réussi la lucarne j'ai
proposé au Président Bédié de pouvoir
accueillir 10 étapes dans le département
des Yvelines ce qu'il a fait par exemple
à Poissy nous avons effectué un samedi
après-midi place de la République le jeu
de la lucarne ils avaient transféré une
lucarne amovible
500 jeunes et intergénérationnels ont pu
taper dans le ballon mais on a aussi
tiré le fil parce que c'est aussi encore
une fois une manière de démarrer avec un
ballon mais de dire qu'il y a un
écosystème au travers de cela et donc on
a fait un forum de l'emploi forme de
l'emploi avec des entreprises qui sont
venu recruter des jeunes qui s'appellent
dans le ballon qui sont venus aider des
jeunes à remplir un CV avec la Mission
Locale donc vous voyez au-delà de ça ça
me paraît important de valoriser ces
jeunes on a la possibilité d'installer
des lucarnes amovibles c'est ce que je
veux aussi proposer au département et
puis j'ai aussi défié qu'il y a Mbappé
de pouvoir faire cette cette lucarne
Kylian il est originaire de Bondy mais
c'est un tel ambassadeur Kylian Mbappé
que ce serait formidable dans un contrat
gagnant-gagnant alors je suis heureux
d'y être allé je suis heureux d'avoir
mis la lucarne mais au-delà du geste du
geste sportif c'est aussi une envie de
tendre la main à celles et ceux qui sont
pour moi bien trop stigmatisés et je
fais un clin d'oeil voilà à mala et
swahili à goy et puis à assamir qui qui
sont à l'origine de cette très très
belle initiative merci beaucoup car le
livre c'est moi d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle donc que vous êtes députés de
la deuxième circonscription des Yvelines
et nous on se retrouve dimanche prochain
pour un nouveau numéro de libre
politique sur Radio sensation et sur TV
78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]